it is a cold and bleak day here
there are lots of towns and villages
around the world that once existed but
have been lost to the sea or under flood
waters
but here on the southeast coast of
britain there's a village that's still
around
but which won't be for too long up
behind those cliffs
is cove hive it's a picturesque little
village there's the ruins of a church
more than 600 years old with a more
recent church built inside
and by more recent i mean the little
church is only 400 years old
there's farmland a few houses a couple
of dozen residents this has been a
settlement for at least a thousand years
possibly more and it'll be gone by the
end of the century
you can see on old maps just how much
land has already been lost to the sea
these cliffs here get eroded a little
bit with every high tide
steadily being pushed back and back and
back there are warning signs to stop
people from walking on top
because the ground near the edge will be
loose and could fall with just a little
bit of pressure from above
and this has been happening for
centuries it can't go on forever
at some point no one knows when the
process should stabilize as new
equilibrium but
no one can model that far ahead for the
foreseeable future the local council's
management plan estimates that the
coastline
will move inland by about four or five
meters every year
there's a lot of margin forever but even
in the best case scenario
cove hive is gone in a hundred years
worst case
thirty years it won't actually crumble
into the ocean to avoid pollution
buildings around here are demolished and
taken away when their time comes and
presumably someone will have to move the
church's graveyard
so why doesn't anyone save cove hive the
landowners did offer to build their own
coastal defenses back in 2011 to add
breakwaters here as an experiment to see
if the erosion could be slowed but
they were turned down by the council
this beach where they need to build
is owned by the government and the
government said no
because the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few
a little way down the coast is southward
home to a thousand people
and a lot of tourism and the simulations
say that if cove hive
stops eroding then southward would
probably start
or at least they'd need much much
stronger defenses it's not practical to
save every building everywhere
this is miles of coastline and they need
to defend all of it constantly
into eternity the council's plan is
clear it is not considered sustainable
to attempt to manage the erosion i did
ask both the landowners and the council
for a comment but neither got back to me
perhaps because cove hide isn't a
tourist attraction and
i don't think they'd want to be there
are no amenities for visitors there's no
little tea shop by the beach
but if you do happen to be somewhere in
the area in the next few years
it might be worth stopping by to see
covered
while you can
you